the movie opens up inside a passenger
plane ia-42 which is flying from dallas
to london the pilot captain william
strong is briefing the situation of the
flight and mentions that they should
reach their destination in about seven
hours he also says that the weather
conditions are perfect and that they
will not face any hindrances along the
way captain strong is accompanied by
co-pilot daniel prentiss with whom he
has flown several flights together as
the duo is talking a strange anomaly
suddenly occurs the electronics inside
the cockpit start flickering and this
prompts captain strong to call for help
fortunately the ground control assures
him that they don't have any mechanical
problems and that the skies ahead are
clear with this the pilots get relieved
but just when they reach a bit ahead
they notice a gigantic storm brewing
taken aback captain strong immediately
contacts the ground control again as the
latter had just mentioned that the skies
would be clear however to their surprise
the man mentions that the storm appeared
out of nowhere left with no options
captain strong urges the passengers to
remain in their seats and proceeds to
get through the storm co-pilot daniel is
unsure about the idea but the captain
tells him it's the only way after this
both of them brace through the intense
turbulence while the passengers scream
in fear fortunately after a bit of a
scare the plane passes through the storm
and enters smooth skies while the
passengers breathe a sigh of relief the
pilots are stunned to see the skies
completely dark as if it has become
night moreover all the signals inside
the plane are also cut off now only the
radar is working and all communications
to the ground control are lost despite
this they assume that it's just a
malfunction caused by the storm and
continue proceeding forward however when
they fail to find a single aircraft on
their radar for the next 30 minutes they
start getting suspicious captain strong
decides to fly the plane in a loop
aiming to find someone around before
doing so he calls one of the flight
attendants cameron and asks her to
settle everyone in their seats as they
will be making a descent in the next
scene the pilots start descending as per
their plan and just then they notice
something on their radar at first the
captain is happy but when daniel
mentions that it's not a normal aircraft
he starts getting scared lo and behold
they see a large number of fighter
planes bombarding a city in what appears
to be a war this sends the passengers
into a state of panic but the flight
attendants quickly calm them down
mentioning that everything will be fine
meanwhile inside the cockpit the pilots
are equally stunned but just as they
investigate the situation a bunch of
fighter planes start circling them as
they are about to be attacked they use
their radar to get away from the firing
line and again ascend into the sky with
this the danger gets averted for the
time being but the passengers start
getting more anxious by the minute some
of them demand that cameron reveal
what's happening but she calmly assures
them that everything is under control in
the meantime captain strong fails to
connect with anyone on the ground and
since he has no clue about their current
location he decides to descend once
again the plan is to inspect their
surroundings and deduce the exact
location they're in daniel immediately
disagrees as he is wary of the threat
looming below however when the captain
mentions that they'll soon run out of
fuel he agrees meanwhile two passengers
who are revealed to be historians dale
and bennett find the situation odd and
decide to inform the captain about it
they then sneak up inside the cockpit
and inform captain strong that the
fighter planes they just witnessed have
not been made since 1945.
in fact they are the luftwaffe which
were owned and operated by wait for it
the nazis hearing this captain strong
becomes enraged and he orders cameron to
escort the men out of the cockpit but
bennett keeps mentioning that they have
somehow time traveled back to 1940
amidst world war ii the historians find
out that the plane has lost all signal
and because of this captain strong
reluctantly gives them 30 seconds to
explain their story after this the guys
reveal that the plane is failing to
catch any signals because there were not
many radio towers on the western allied
front in 1940 they also mentioned that
the plane flew through the bombing of
saint azare which was a calculated nazi
attack on the west coast of france in
1940. meanwhile the speculations simply
anger the captain even more and he
assumes that the historians are fooling
around with him he then sends them away
to their seats but not before telling
them to keep their mouths shut in the
next scene the pilots once again lower
the aircraft hoping to catch any radio
signals luckily they managed to contact
a british guy who immediately asks the
captain to identify himself captain
strong obliges and also mentions that
they need immediate help but the guy on
the radio nigel is skeptical about their
motives he believes that it is
impossible to catch a radio signal from
an airplane which is flying at a high
altitude and rightly so during the
second world war the british did not
have such advanced equipment to
intercept long-range transmissions with
time running out captain strong begs
nigel for help but the latter is
confused about their identity as a
result captain strong asks nigel for the
date and he replies that it's the 17th
of june 1940. this shocks the captains
and they finally realized that the
historians were not lying however they
are still unable to convince nigel that
they are a commercial plane with no
options left captain strong calls in the
historians and lets them talk to nigel
bennett deduces a rough location through
his assumptions and also mentions that
they have passed the spot where the
lancastria was sunk hearing this nigel
is taken aback as in his time the
lancastria is still active he then
decides to head to his superior and
confirm if the guys are speaking the
truth back inside the airplane a
passenger overhears the conversation
inside the cockpit and gets wind of the
situation he then decides to take
matters into his own hands and gets up
from his seat following this he
announces to everyone that the airplane
has somehow traveled back into 1940 and
they are now over france he also
mentions that hitler's army is currently
invading the country and proposes that
they all work together to stop him
thinking he's probably just trying to go
viral on tick-tock they call him a
lunatic however some of them agree to
join him with this the newly formed
group decides to hijack the cockpit and
make a crash landing but they are soon
stopped by a couple of us soldiers soon
a fight breaks out and even the flight
attendants join in on the action luckily
the bad guys are subdued and they are
tied to their seats so that they don't
cause any further disturbance meanwhile
nigel again contacts the pilots and
reveals that their information about the
lancastria was right he also mentions
that the information helped them rescue
a lot of people as a result nigel
finally trusts captain strong and
decides to help him land the plane but
for that he will need their exact
location captain strong and the
historians give a rough estimate of
their location but it is still not
enough hence the co-pilot comes up with
a plan to turn back their lights so that
they can be visible to the british
soldiers sadly as soon as he does so the
germans find them first and a bunch of
fighter planes starts surrounding them
they start pelting the aircraft with
bullets sending the passengers into a
state of total chaos despite this
captain strong doesn't panic and he
tries his best to avert the attack he
then comes up with a plan to lose the
luftwaffe on the count of three he drops
the plane at a very steep angle and as
it is about to hit the ground he pulls
it up the germans also follow but since
they don't have advanced planes they
fail to rise up and hence crash to the
ground you would think trained fighter
pilots would know better in the next
scene it is revealed that daniel got
shot during the attack and the aircraft
is reeling with several holes in it
cameron quickly plugs the holes and
administers first aid to daniel
following this captain strong finally
decides to confront the scared
passengers he asks one of the flight
attendants to take over the wheel and
heads out there he reveals the entire
situation and also mentions that they
are trying their best to land the plane
however the recent attack damaged the
plane's landing gear so they will
require some volunteers to fix it at
first everyone stays silent as they are
scared to death but soon two brave
passengers teresa and hector agree to
volunteer soon the trio heads down the
tail section of the aircraft and starts
investigating teresa being an engineer
quickly identifies the problem and
starts fixing it after a while she is
successful but there is one last
obstacle the landing gear is jammed with
something hence in order to fix it
someone will have to go down there and
remove the object being the brave man
that he is captain strong immediately
agrees to risk his life even though he's
the only guy that can fly the damn plane
but hector smartly insists that he do it
since the captain is of more importance
he then slowly makes his way down to the
landing gear and using a hammer fixes
the problem later captain strong heads
back to the cockpit and again descends
to establish connection with nigel after
he does so he mentions that the aircraft
has only 80 minutes worth of fuel left
in it so they need help immediately as
they are talking two german aircraft
suddenly attack the airplane this time
they even fire missiles which blows out
all the windows of the plane with all
the passengers in a state of shock
captain strong comes up with another
plan to evade the enemies he uses his
only form of equipment the radar to
track the enemies he then cleverly
tricks the germans and makes them crash
into each other hence saving everyone's
lives after the close call daniel
realizes that they can't keep descending
as it will reveal their location to the
germans just when all hope seems to be
lost bennett comes up with an idea he
proposes that they cut off the airplane
radar and send it over to nigel so that
he can use it and guide them through to
safety the captains are hesitant about
the plan but they have no other choice
so they agree following this they
re-establish contact with nigel and
brief him on their plan nigel is
surprised that they're willing to give
up on their best weapon but he
nonetheless agrees to help the pilots
then agree to hand over the radar at a
specific location and start preparing
for it in the next scene the flight
attendant starts searching through the
luggage haphazardly hoping to find
something useful that can cushion the
landing just then an old man hands them
over some toy parachutes which he had
supposedly picked up for his grandkids
after this the preparations for the drop
begin they quickly wrap the radar in a
thick layer of clothes and suspend it
with the parachutes after a while they
reach the designated spot chuck the
device out of the plane and inform nigel
about the drop sadly the package lands
right near the swiss german border and
it is discovered by the nazis first
right then some members of the british
army arrive there and an intense
shootout ensues between the two parties
fortunately the nazis are killed and the
british take the package to nigel
wasting no time he quickly sets up the
radar inside his base and starts
operating it he then guides captain
strong with the help of the device until
they reach a safe place by this time the
aircraft is running incredibly low on
fuel and the captain requests nigel to
find a landing spot as soon as possible
as he is skimming through the place he
suddenly spots a large blip on the radar
which doesn't look like any aircraft
surprisingly the blip turns out to be
another storm similar to the one which
teleported them into this world seeing
this captain strong suggests they go
through it as they don't have enough
fuel to land elsewhere he then bids
nigel goodbye and thanks him for his
assistance after this he announces to
the passengers that they will be going
through another storm and if they are
lucky they will meet each other soon
captain strong then braces himself and
along with daniel plunges the aircraft
into the storm fortunately their plan
works and the aircraft is teleported
back to present day in berlin the ground
control there contacts them and mentions
that the whole runway has been cleared
for them to land at last after six hours
of chaos and terror flight ia-42 finally
lands in the final scene of the movie
all the passengers celebrate the landing
and start heading out one by one after a
while captain strong also gets out of
the cockpit and finds the same old man
sitting alone inside the plane he
appears to be writing a book titled the
radar system that saved europe the movie
ends as the old man is revealed to be
none other than nigel himself this movie
was based on a true story just kidding
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching